Starbucks has opened its first bilingual
store in the u.s. for customers who are
deaf or hard of hearing all of the
employees at the new location in
Washington DC are fluent in sign
language Errol Barnett is outside the
Starbucks signing store where he learned
a few different ways to order for
himself Errol good morning good morning
Gail I've actually been able to sneak
inside or should say good morning it is
not unusual to see people in this part
of DC using sign language because we are
close to the world's largest School for
the Deaf and with steps from the US
Capitol
but for Starbucks it's a perfect place
an opportunity to show what inclusion
looks like call it a sign of the times
instead of calling out names at this
Starbucks
they've gone silent even those with a
little bit of resistance coming in and
once they have this experience they
become our allies this signing Starbucks
the first of its kind in the u.s. is a
hands-on experience
this means macchiato cold brew and
pumpkin spice manager matthew gills buck
who like all the employees here is
either fully or partially deaf taught me
a few others coffee is this I can do
that orders appear on this screen and
there's an abundance of anti-glare table
tops to eliminate distractions how big
of a difference does being able to do
something like this make in someone's
life who thought of hearing well
Starbucks is more than just a cup of
coffee it provides an experience people
come here as their third place the idea
has been brewing since videos like this
when a customer at this Starbucks
drive-thru couldn't order until a
barista appeared on the screen
Starbucks got a wake-up call after this
Philadelphia store called police on two
african-american men Howard Schultz then
Starbucks executive chairman spoke to
Gail King in April we want to be an
inviting welcoming place the coffee
giant closed all 8,000 stores for anti
buyers training and now sees this store
as an effort at include
70% of deaf and hard-of-hearing people
are either unemployed entirely or
underemployed so it's a way to give back
to the community and on its first day of
business
Gil box showed me how to order using
American Sign Language I would like a
copy so grinding the coffee grounds here
moments later how do you say cheers even
though it's a coffee I know that one
welllook Starbucks says there are no
plans to have other stores specifically
designed for the deaf but they say the
point is for this store to be a real
part of this community up and down H
Street and provide opportunities join
other businesses that are employing
those who are deaf and hard of hearing
Breanna you know my aunt and uncle are
deaf thank you for that by the way here
oh my and uncle are deaf and it's so
meaningful to hear stories like this
from Starbucks and other companies that
employ deaf people into the community
I'm gonna be taking them to wash it off
that's our bucks and what we just
learned is that cheers is a universal
sign everybody knows with that man this
is thank you that's thank you guys